he was the personification of the evil
dictator clad in his familiar khaki
uniform and cap and chomping on a cigar
he ruled with an iron fist over his
island nation he took on the United
States and brought the world to the
brink of nuclear holocaust shifting his
attention to his own country he
decimated the economy creating a
communistic dictatorship that forced the
people to revere him even as he ruined
their lives in this episode of
biographic s-- we take a closer look at
the life of Fidel Castro
[Music]
Fidel Castro was born on August the 13th
1926 in the small farming village of
Monaco's in northern Oriente in Cuba
his father and hell Castro Gyges had
emigrated from Spain in 1898 and picked
up work as a bricklayer and railroad
worker before starting his own business
selling lemonade to field workers from
this humble start he built a small
sugarcane Empire comprising 26,000 acres
and 300 worker families and hell's first
wife Maria our Goethe gave birth to two
children and then Eva died or simply
walked out on the family and he'll soon
took up with his young mate Lena Roos
Gonzales who bore him three children and
yella
Ramon and Fidel the couple were married
shortly after Fidel's birth they were a
relatively wealthy family who lived in a
Galician style 2-story house in the
country still they did live a decidedly
country lifestyle with chickens and pigs
wandering through the house Fidel was
named after a local politician with his
name meaning faithful he did have his
father's temperament which meant he was
prone to violent outbursts
his sister recalls that if he was
playing baseball and his team were
losing he would simply gather up the
equipment and walk off the field close
friends and future novelist Gabriel
Garcia Marquez recalled that Fidel was
the worst loser that had ever met
when he reached school age Fidel was
sent to study in Santiago the second
largest city in Cuba for the first two
years he stayed with his godparents and
was homeschooled by them after that he
was enrolled at the merits La Salle
school along with brothers Ramon and
Rowell Fidel soon gained a reputation as
a troublemaker and a bit of a bully when
he was in the fourth grade Fidel father
received a letter stating that his three
boys with the biggest bullies in the
entire school and help was furious and
pulled the boys out of the school this
enraged Fidel who threatened to burn the
house down
he ended up being sent to a more
demanding Jesuit School in Havana with
his father threatening to cut off his
allowance if his grades dropped below a
certain level Fidel responded to this by
forging his school reports Caspari
proved to be a decidedly average
students but there was one area in which
he excelled he had a photographic memory
a fact which hugely impressed his fellow
students they would call him to a page
number from their textbooks and he would
recite the page word-for-word in his
teens Fidel began to develop his
as a public speaker and as a debater
after an initial rejection he gained
acceptance into the aluva nada literary
Academy which was the literary wing at
the Jesuit school at first he was
paralyzed by stage fright but he
gradually became more relaxed and more
confident in his presentations in
October of 1945 Fidel entered law school
at the University of Havana at the time
the university was the self governing
body which forbade the police or army
from setting foot on campus as a result
it was a hotbed of clandestine activity
by gangsters and political agitators it
was a very attractive environment for
the hot-headed Castro Fidel's first
foray into political agitation was
precipitated by a rise in bus fares that
had been authorized by Cuban President
Ramon growl Castro organized a protest
against the fair aizen's led a march to
the presidential palace the police beat
the students with Fidel himself
receiving slight injuries he used this
incident she was advantage by going to
the press and receiving some sympathetic
coverage at the time the Castro enrolled
at the University there were two main
gangster groups who were vying for
control the socialist revolutionary
movement MSR and the insurrectional
revolutionary Union you I are there were
frequent violent clashes between these
two groups Fidel quickly sized up the
situation and began to maneuver between
the two groups in December of 1946 there
was an assassination attempt on a
leading member of the uir and Castro was
fingered as the triggerman his assumed
motive here was that he wanted to
ingratiate himself with the MSR
leadership as it turns out it was the
leader of uir Emilio Troy who took
Castro under his wing he gave Fidel a
pistol which the young budding
revolutionary carried with him at all
times
Troy had been planning an invasion of
the Dominican Republic in conjunction
with a group of Dominican xl's in
response to the terrible conditions
brought about by the rule of Rafael
through a hawk Castro quickly jumps on
board and sailed with about 12,000
fellow revolutionaries Takaya con fetus
on July the 29th 1947 for two months
they underwent paramilitary training
before setting off for the Dominican
mainland meanwhile three Ho
of the plans attack and that even
appealed to the United States for eight
the revolutionary leaders got cold feet
and cooled off the invasion and the
embarrassed Cuban army again rounding up
the ships and taking the would-be
attackers into custody
Castro managed to evade custody by
jumping ship and swimming eight miles to
the shore in 1947 Castro visitors a new
model prison on the Isle of Pines as
part of his legal studies when he
returned to Havana he criticized the
prison and its inhumane treatment of its
inhabitants the following year he was
part of a student Congress that traveled
to bogota colombia my brother seventh
the group met with the leader of the
Liberal Party jorge Gaytan who looked
likely to win the upcoming election two
days later though Gaytan was shot dead
bergüzar erupted in violence and these
students from Cuba were caught in the
middle of it Castro became actively
involved participating in the takeover
of a police station after three days the
authorities restored order but not
before some 3,500 people had been killed
Castro returns a Havana where he became
a follower of Senator Eddie he busts the
main opponents of President growl heba's
was the founder of the Cubans people
party Castro campaigned hard for heba's
in his unsuccessful bid for the
presidency in 1948 still the two men
were never close he besought Fidel as
somewhat of an embarrassment due to his
gangster backgrounds and Fidel only ever
viewed the leader as an obstacle to his
own path to power
[Music]
in order to gain political
respectability Castro cut off his
association with his gangster associates
he gave speeches on campus denouncing
the two main gangs and naming names of
those who were responsible for criminal
activity this made him a target for both
groups and he was forced into hiding
around this time Fidel who was generally
awkward and shy around women met murder
diaz-balart the daughter of one of the
wealthiest men in Cuba the couple fell
in love and were married in 1948 with
mirta's father and getting them $10,000
for a three-month honeymoon in the
United States most of their time was
spent in New York where Fidel learned
some English returning to Cuba the
newlyweds moved into a hotel across the
street from a military camp in Havana in
September of 1949 mutter gave birth to a
son who had become known as fidelito
having graduated from university Fidel
began a small law practice most of his
time however we spent dabbling in
politics on August the 15th 1951
People's Party leader Eddie Hughes was
giving his usual Sunday radio address
urging the people to stop accepting the
corruption of the government and take
action he then pulled out a pistol and
shot himself in the stomach the dramatic
act was intended to rouse the people but
he bus had spoken for too long and his
suicide attempt it's not broadcast for
the next 11 days he bus lay in a
hospital bed in terrible agony at his
side the entire time was Fidel Castro
when the leader died Castro was
prominence as part of the honor guard
that stood outside the University Hall
of Honor where he vows layin state as
the military escort prepared to lead the
body through the streets in a large
procession Castro entreated the captain
to divert the route to the presidential
palace Fidel was convinced that he could
rouse the people to overthrow the
government but the army captain refused
fearing that an absolute bloodbath
wouldn't assume the following year
Castro ran for a seat on the Chamber of
Deputies he managed to garner the
support of the majority of the people's
party members and looked in line to win
the upcoming election however on March
the tenth former president's full NCO
Batista staged a military coup and
seized power
he began rounding up his political
adversaries including members of the
People's Party Fidel and his brother all
went
hiding that Easter COO diverted Castro
from what could have been a promising
diplomatic career in favor of becoming a
fully fledged revolutionary he gathered
together his own political group drawn
from former party members and followers
from his university days traveling up
and down the country he put his
oratorical and propaganda skills to full
effect after 14 months he had a
following of 12,000 people
Castro ran his organization with
military precision and discipline
drinking alcohol was forbidden and he
imposed strict sexual standards he also
organized his forces at a cellular level
with members of each cell being unaware
of the existence of other cells by the
middle of 1953 Castro had the support
base that he needed to stage his own
coup but he didn't have they were
weapons or indeed the money to buy them
his solution was to attack a military
base and seize its weapons the base
selected was located at moncada the
attack however was bungled from the
start one of the 26 vehicles on route to
the base had a flat tire another took a
wrong turn and did not arrive until the
attack was well underway when the
remainder of the vehicles arrived at the
base they were surprised to find it
heavily fortified the military defenders
soon beat back the invaders with 8 of
Castro's men being killed
the remainder fled but over the next few
days many of them rounded up by the
authorities 69 of them were eventually
tortured and put to death
Castro himself was put on trial before a
military tribunal he used the
opportunity to speak out about the
regime of Batista and the harsh
treatment of his fellow revolutionaries
his courtroom defense statement of
history will absolve me would become
that probably his most famous speech
still he was convicted and sentenced to
15 years imprisonment Castro and his
followers were sent to the
previously-mentioned
Isle of Pines prison Fidel mused his
time there to instill a supreme level of
order and discipline in his men the
Castro rebels gains a reputation for
their good behavior and were given great
freedom then on March the 6th 1954
bowing to public pressure president
Batista granted amnesty to Castro and
his men the show of good faith from the
presidents however did not stop Castro
from speaking out about the regime when
two of his men were beaten by Batista
and forces Fidel became
increasingly concerned for his own
safety he would move houses every two to
three days and then just two months
after being released from prison he left
Cuba for Mexico
it was Castro's plan to build up and
train a new wing of his Revolutionary
Army in Mexico and then returned to join
forces with those already in Havana and
a huge push to oust the Batista regime
his Mexican army began as a group of
about 60 Cuban defectors who lived in
six small houses under strict
disciplinary conditions imposed by Fidel
it was during this period for Castro met
Ernesto Che Guevara who would play a key
role in the coming revolution Castro
launched his revolution in late November
1956 from the port of tuks pan on the
Mexican coast it was planned to coincide
with another uprising organized by a
rival and Dibattista group Fidel had
bought a 60-foot boat that was designed
to take a maximum of 25 passengers and
he piled 82 of his men on board as it
chugged its way towards Cuba the boat
was in constant danger of capsizing the
journey was so slow that the plans 5-day
trip took seven days meaning that they
would miss the uprising of the other
group the boat beached at a place called
purgatory points on December 2nd but by
now Batista's army who had already put
down the first rebellion had learned
that Castro was on his way and that he
had planes overhead ready to strafe the
invaders and bomb the area only about a
dozen men survived Castro and Guevara
among them they began a three-day march
through the forest constantly being
hounded from the air by the Cuban Air
Force they finally reached the Sierra
Maestra region where they settled with
the local villagers and began to regroup
six weeks later Castro led 33 men on a
guerrilla raid on a tiny army garrison
in La Plata two soldiers were killed and
the rebels stole off with a number of
weapons a month after this attack Castro
decided it was time to get its
propaganda machine in motion he sent one
of his men to Havana to bring a foreign
journalist back to the camp the man
chosen was from the New York Times and
soon a three-part story had appeared in
the paper describing the massive
military buildup that Castro was
organizing in the south of Cuba Castro
support base grew exponentially with
more and more disaffected Cubans joining
his ranks in March of 1958 younger
brother Raul began to establish a second
force out of Oriente which soon grew in
number Raul proved to be a
capable military commander with his
force capturing and destroying many
planes tanks and military vehicles in
april fidel called upon the people of
Cuba to stage a nationwide strike he
believed that this would be the start of
his long planned uprising president
Batista responded by threatening to
shoot anyone who participated in the
strike as a result more than a hundred
and forty people were shot down in the
street but this action only fueled
Castro's support base and even more
people streamed to support him with the
tide now decidedly turned in his favor
Castro decided to move
he sent Che Guevara and another of his
commanders Camilo Cienfuegos on a
westward march toward Savannah along
with their rebel forces the government
forces put up virtually no resistance
and the rebels weren't able to take
control one town after another on
December the 31st 1958 with Castro's men
closing in
Batista resigned and fled the country
three days later Castro arrived in
Santiago to a hero's welcome he gave a
speech in front of 200,000 people hours
later Guevara or in cienfuegos marched
into Havana and seized control of the
reins of power and just like that the
Castro era had begun
[Music]
the transfer of power was amazingly
orderly Castro had warned his men
against looting or destroying property
he had come to power on the backs of an
army of poor and illiterate peasants now
that he had gained power he would need
to educate men to help him govern he
chose to appoint his former professor
Jose Mero Cardona as prime minister and
Manuel arisia to the president he made
himself supreme commander of the armed
forces behind the scenes however gastric
put the organization in place to ensure
that he was the holder of overall power
in the weeks following the revolution
more than 500 Batista officials were
tried convicted and put to death that
number would rise to 1,900 over the
coming year within seven months of
seizing power Castro decided that he no
longer had any need for a public
government on July the 16th he announced
that he was resigning his position as
army commander because he could no
longer work with president a reach M who
had accused him of corruption Castro
then disappeared for a number of days
just as Fidel had intended the people
who rose up in protest and demanded that
the president must go the frightened
president sought sanctuary in the
Venezuelan embassy before escaping the
country this allowed Castro to return in
triumph and to point himself as
president Castro now imposed
totalitarian rule those who did not give
him their absolute support we're in
danger of being seized and put on trial
or just simply shot within a few short
months all signs of resistance within
Cuba including critical media had simply
been removed now Castro fixed his
attention on securing external security
a focus was put on increasing the size
and the strength of his army six months
after seizing power Castro visited the
United States where he was greeted with
enthusiasm by the media as well as
politicians and the public behind the
scenes however the Eisenhower government
was already making plans for Castro's
removal
in February of 1960 the Cuban leader
signed an agreements with the Russians
by which Cuban sugar would be traded for
military arms and oil this was at the
height of the Cold War and many of the
oil refineries in Cuba were American
owned when the owners refused to process
Soviet oil imports Castro seized their
businesses the US government responded
by cutting 700,000 tons from the US and
your purchase commitments in turn Castro
nationalized us owned agriculture and
industrial businesses Castro's move had
a huge impact on the US mafia which lost
about a hundred million dollars worth of
property in the tourist industry alone
during this period of nationalization
more than 200 thousands professional and
upper class citizens fled the country
relations between the United States and
Cuban government's became so strange
that in March of 1960 President
Eisenhower dream let's the training of a
group of Cuba Nexus to stage an invasion
and seek control the ball was picked up
by President Kennedy resulting in the
disastrous Bay of Pigs invasion Castro
had gotten winds of the invasion and had
his forces ready and waiting with their
lack of promised US air support the
Cuban rebels were cut to pieces on
December the 1st 1961 Castro went on
national television and declared that he
was a Marxist Leninist and would be
until the day he died the Soviets took a
weary view of their newly declared
communist fellow that the Americans
responded immediately imposing a total
economic blockade on Cuba this led to
economic disaster with massive food
shortages resulting finally the Soviet
government decided to embrace Castro
they offered to station Soviet missiles
on the islands in mid-october 1962 the
American governments got concrete
evidence of the missile operation
leading to what became known as the
Cuban Missile Crisis President Kennedy
placed a total military blockade around
Cuba and announced that a military
attack from Cuba on any nation would be
seen as a direct attack by the Soviet
Union on the United States
Castro urged the Russians to make a
preemptive strike on the United States
if the Americans attacked the islands
after 13 days during which the world was
a hair-trigger away from nuclear
destruction the russians backed down and
agreed to remove the missiles castro was
left complete
out of the negotiation process and he
was not happy Soviet President Nikita
Khrushchev tried to placate him by
inviting Castro on a forty day trip
through the Soviet Union during the trip
Khrushchev offered to provide economic
aid to the struggling Island in 1965 the
United States announced that it was
willing to take in Cuban refugees this
led to a mass exodus with a resultant
huge loss of skills and manpower on the
island
[Music]
with the international situation having
settled Castro said his focus on making
agricultural reforms to improve the
economy he wanted to increase the sugar
harvest and set a target for national
production in 1965 of 5.5 million tons
increasing to 10 million tonnes by 1970
these expectations however they were
totally unreasonable still he poured
nearly all of the country's economic
resources into the sugarcane industry
leaving all other economic activity
barren the whole country including the
elderly young children and military
workers were put to work in the fields
in a desperate quest to reach his
targets even Castro himself was said to
have cut cane for four hours every day
as the rest of the Cuban economy fell by
20 and 40 percent the sugar cane project
failed dismally to reach its projected
targets in 1970 Castro announced that
the plan had failed typical of his flair
for the dramatic he resigned his
presidency the people demanded that he
returned though and soon he was back in
power and the sugar cane crisis was
behind him throughout the 1970s Castro
began looking for ways to extend his
influence abroad he began involving
himself in revolutionary movements and
sending forces to train and lead various
guerrilla operations his support of
civil wars in angola and somalia
ate up more of his country's limited
resources during the early 1980s sugar
prices and production had increased
significantly
this allowed the Cuban economy to grow
at a rate of 24 percent but when the
sugar price slumped dramatically Cuba's
international debt ballooned to 6
billion dollars at the same time it
still owed 19 billion dollars to the
Soviet Union the Soviets tried to help
by increasing trade but with the fall of
the Soviet Union in 1989 all the
agreements fell apart the already weak
human economy was severely restricted
strict rationing was put in place the
electricity supply became sporadic and
tractors were replaced with ox-drawn
carts with his country on the brink of
collapse in 1993
Castro allowed Cubans to start private
businesses the following year he
permitted foreign investors to own given
businesses as well the economy which had
declined by 40% in the past three years
finally began to grow
by the 1990s castrate was an aging
isolated and largely depressed dictator
the majority of his closest associates
were either dead or had been exiled he
still kept up his habit of staying in
one place for only two or three nights
so it was constantly being moved around
in a bulletproof mercedes limousine
during this period Castro's tight grip
on the country seemed to loosen slightly
but then in March of 2003 he imposed a
crackdown which saw scores of
journalists students and professional
people arrested as dissidents of the
regime in July of 2006 the
eight-year-old Castro underwent surgery
for internal bleeding the following year
he handed over the presidential reins to
his brother role from then Fidel's
health gradually deteriorated the ends
finally came on November the 26th 2016
though the exact cause of his death was
never released the country was in
mourning for nine days so I really hope
you enjoyed that episode of biographic
s-- if you did there's a couple of
things you could do right now one is hit
that like button below also if you want
more stuff like this we put out brand
new videos every Monday and every
Thursday so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button doesn't do
what it used to on YouTube if you
actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next to the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday we
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]
you